Olá será que você entende o que que seus
exames de tireoide dizem sobre a sua
saúde vamos desvendar isso agora usando
o conceito de quarti e o caso real de um
paciente que passou aqui no
consultório Primeiro vamos falar sobre o
TSH que é o hormônio que estimula a
tireoide só que tem muita gente que
pensa que o TSH ele é produzido na
tiroide mas não é ele é produzido na
hipófise então o resultado aqui do exame
deu
2,37 e os valores de referência desse
Laboratório São de
0,38 a
5,33 se eu dividir esse intervalo em
quatro partes iguais Quad quartil vai
ser 1,24 então o TSH tá no segundo
quartil isso indica o qu uma função
tiroidiana dentro da Média Mas poderia
estar um pouquinho melhor não está na
faixa ideal a gente considera o ideal
por volta de 1,5 a 2 já o T4 Liv tá na
faixa de
0,85 n por dcl a referência entre
0,54 e
1,2 aqui cada quartil tem
aproximadamente 0,17 então o T4 Liv está
no segundo do segundo pro terceiro
quartil de novo é um pouco abaixo do
ideal esse resultado aqui o T3 livre
está em
3,53 os valores normais é de 1,8 a 4
4,59 então Quada quartil seria de cerca
de 0,7 então o T3 Liv tá no terceiro
quartil isso indica o quê níveis
praticamente ideais desse hormônio ativo
agora presta atenção que no antipo o
antiti peroxidase ele está em
33,8 o ideal é ser inferior a 9 isso
indica o qu uma possível condição
autoimune da tireóide aqui já é um
indicativo de moto que não tá afetando
ainda muito a função
tiroidiana nutrientes como Selene e
Zinco são essenciais então o Zin deles
está em 119 a referência desse
laboratório de 70 a 120 Quada quartil
seria por volta de 12,5 então o nível
está no quarto quartil O que é excelente
para a saúde da tireoide agora a
vitamina D tá longe tá ideal ela tá 31
nesse caso ela deveria estar entre 50 e
70 pro funcionamento ótimo da tireoide o
que eu quero que você preste atenção é
que esses exames facilmente passariam
despercebidos por um médico uma visão
mais Ortodoxa por qu os números da
tiroide estão normais mas não estão
ideais a vitamina D de dado também não
está ideal então o médico mais ortodoxo
ele certamente não pediria o antipo
antiti peroxidase e não ficaria sabendo
que existe um Hashimoto em atividade
aqui então esse paciente ficaria anos
sem nenhum tipo de estratégia
para controlar esses anticorpos da
tireóide Então o que eu quero dizer aqui
mesmo que os exames do paciente estejam
normais entre aspas aqui né normais
entre aspas esse caso ainda demanda
atenção porque esse paciente está com
rachim noto em atividade então se nós
não fizermos nada daqui alguns anos essa
doença autoimune vai evoluir para um
hipotiroidismo Ou seja a tiroide dele
vai ficar fraca então não vai dar tempo
de falar aqui mas se você quiser se
aprofundar sobre esse tema tirite
Hashimoto você pode ver meus vídeos no
canal do YouTube e também ler os artigos
do meu blog sobre esse assunto Hashimoto
uma boa estratégia aqui para esse
paciente além de otimizar os níveis de
selênio iodo magnésio Complexo B
vitaminas a c d e e seria o uso do ldn
né a nutrex Sona de baixa dosagem o low
doose nutrex o zinco dele não precisaria
mexer aqui porque tá bom percebe a
importância de um olhar atento e
abrangente entenderem qual artigo você
se encontra nos exames pode ajudar muito
a evitar problemas lá na frente então
fica atento aos sinais Procure um bom
médico que ten um olhar atento um
conhecimento mais integrado e mais amplo
dos seus problemas de saúde Então você
tá acompanhando a saúde da sua tiroide
Salve esse vídeo para consultar na
próxima vez que você fizer Esses exames
E compartilhe com alguém que precisa
muito dessas informações um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração